well hello Queen well hello Queen
good to see you first of all this album
was released the same day as two other
queens Taylor Swift and Carly Rae Jepsen
so when you first heard this what was
your reaction because usually artists
know
in advance that this could be a
possibility a collision I yeah I um it
was a surprise because T Swift is the
queen of surprises you know yeah
um but then I I'm such a fan that I was
like oh 13. yep she's adding up duh this
makes sense
um and then I I just knew also like I
felt like I was a part of a a
celebration of Pop Queens like that it's
like a big woman moment for all three of
us like Carly Rae Jepsen too it and I
saw Taylor at Fallon recently when we
were both promoting our album and I
looked at him I was like Girl by the way
sorry that I picked your special day I
didn't know it was a surprise and she
was like it's literally fine I was like
okay good so I think I think it just
works out for all of us because it makes
more people are like going to find new
music that day you know yeah what does
it mean for you to have your fans Still
Standing your new material like the way
they come out every time it's it's
bananas it's yeah in a land I I can't
believe that
um they're still there like I went to
The Today Show recently in New York and
I I see fans that I've known since 2014.
yeah and they're like growing up and
like having babies and I'm like I'm
having babies too it's crazy it's it's a
really beautiful thing that not a lot of
people get to experience and I just feel
so lucky that I have them and I love
them all so much yeah the made you look
video
you know looking like a snack okay yo
thank you oh well let's talk about that
I feel like you could have a cameo in
the new Barbie movies yeah I wanted it
to be bright and beautiful I've been
studying a lot about all of a lot of all
about that bass I've been trying to
figure out what made that so
um huge and I'm a music video and the
music and I wanted to do like that but
2.0 you know I wanted to do bright fun
colorful and like exciting I also
partnered with Candy Crush Saga and they
like helped us make the music video
extra delicious with all the candy and
everything and it just looks fun and I
knew I wanted like my son like toddlers
to watch it and go you know it's pretty
that is so sweet and you do have celeb
cameos JoJo siwa your husband I have
yeah I'm lucky I married a celebrity
um and that I have really nice friends
and I was and they like they were in the
heat all day for me all day it was like
um the hottest day in L.A and we went we
rented this big house that had no air
conditioning oh Lord so they they went
through it for me and I went for like I
started crying in front of them I was
like I'm so sorry and since he was like
you don't cry you're a boss queen All
About That Bass star and I was like okay
so you really they did the most for me
did it take a lot of convincing
initially to get them to be in it oh no
I was like like Jojo siwa was so busy
that I was like what are you doing on
this date and she was like
I'm being with you aren't I and I was
like
I love it
um I want to thank you for opening up
about your anxiety because I struggle
with anxiety and I feel like you're
always so vocal about so many things and
you're so authentic and I just love this
about you
um what has your response been what have
you been receiving
um from other people just in terms of
anxiety and speaking out about it oh
that they're um like what you said like
thank you for talking about it because
it makes them feel less alone and you
know I I felt crazy I thought that I was
like literally going to be in a psych
ward like the way my brain was attacking
my body and uh and like to know I didn't
have control of that was the scariest
thing ever and I couldn't explain it to
my own mom and who's my best friend with
me every day it's like she thought I was
like pretty crazy for going
I need an oxygen tank like you don't
understand
um and then Carson Daley talked about it
on the Today Show and I sent that clip
to my mom and it like clicked for her
like it all made sense and she
understood what I was feeling and she
sobbed and was like I'm so sorry and I'm
here for you and now she looks back in
her life and go oh well that's better
you know like they just yeah they didn't
talk about it back then and now I think
the more we talk about it the more we
feel normal you know because it is it's
okay to have anxiety and to lose control
but once you gain it back I have full
control over my panic attacks and life
life is amazing it totally hijacks your
brain my solution was cold water running
on the hands and chewing gum yeah that's
how I get out of it I also heard if you
like bite into a lemon that it like oh
it shocks your brain to be like lots
going on you know we should just keep
some lemons in our purse then I mean
okay
um you're also super snatched in this
video and you've also been vocal about
your fitness journey
um since the birth of your son so
I feel like you said you lost was it 60
pounds yeah I was like my heaviest I've
ever been I was like
um I was like over 200 pounds but when I
like pushed him out you know a little
c-sectioned them out
um and I just wasn't feeling great I've
never had stitches so like to have this
d-section scar go across the stretch
mark I was like in a really dark place
and I wanted to be in a great place for
my son so I worked every day and
challenged myself and I was like if I
can survive a C-section I could do
anything yeah and I did I dedicated I
was very dedicated and I I started
seeing the pounds like come off like one
week at its time one pound you know and
I was like yeah I'm biting and I I like
learned that I do like healthy food and
I learned what portions mean and I
learned that I love my brain is so happy
when I exercise so I'm just a new and
I'm better than ever
I love this okay okay okay will you
always live your truth you're always
living in your truth you're always
living and being your authentic self
um how does that feel because I wish
more people felt the courage to want to
live a life of Truth honestly
I feel like it has a lot to do with Tick
Tock too like they really accept me for
exactly who I am they accept me for my
two toilets next to each other they
accept me for my my love for me relax
they accept me for my weirdness and and
it makes me more vulnerable and it makes
me want to be more open about everything
because they they're connecting with me
I said how on I'm falling recently I got
my menstrual cycle Auntie Flow came
early and surprised me and all the
comments were like yes girl we're synced
up you know and I was like this is my
place you know they just they're the
best I love it on a scale of one to ten
how confident are you feeling now
oh nowadays I'm a good I'm a good
eight nine you know um
go ahead girl go ahead
I know for this album you were taking it
back to your original style that we were
all introduced to and loved what did
that feel like for you to revisit just
from a from an artist's perspective a
creative mind perspective perspective
what was that process like for you it
was fun and nostalgic and like oh you
know and it was like oh dang I am good
at this you know like the doo-wop I
wrote don't I make it look easy this
that was the second song I wrote for
this album yeah um with my friends and
and it was like I remember I came home
early because we wrote it fast and I
played it for my older brother in the
car and he goes Apple commercial you
know like like oh this is it and then
for everything after that I played that
as inspiration I was like I want to do
this more of this yeah yeah I know that
you look for feedback from your husband
as well and you said that you played
music for him in bed
um how many of these songs from this
album was he like automatically behind
oh
um well all of them he's a Superman you
have to understand I could like wear up
on a truck and he'll be like that's the
one but
he really loves drama queen yeah Queen
he's been and which is crazy because a
lot of now that it's finally out a lot
of people are like drama queen drama
queen he's like I was right
um but yeah he always picks a favorite
and he every single day streams the
album I swear and every single time he's
in the shower he's blasting it oh hi
everybody that's enough you know that's
so cute what is Mom life like for you
now the tongue twister
um is incredible
um I do work a lot and sometimes you
know like how it's like I have a weird
schedule weird job where it's like
cycles of like go go go go and then I'll
have a month off you know which is
beautiful
um so I I have a lot of mom guilt from
not being home so much but I also get to
work from home a lot like I'm home right
now yeah every time I get a break we go
hang out with the baby and he finally
just started saying mama and I'm like no
me you know
oh what is his reaction to your music
videos and your music that's got to be
so cool the first moment that he like
really saw him connect with my music was
for the song taking it back yeah I came
upstairs and I was holding him and I was
like let's dance and we were dancing to
it and he was just melting into me to
the point where I was like is he asleep
there's a video I'll post someday but he
was just so happy and every time the
song stopped he was like you know he was
like put it back on so that's that's
your jam
if you could go back and say anything to
your younger self what would you say
I would say don't worry darling all your
dreams are gonna come true you know why
am I but I would I would hug her and be
like it's gonna be fine I promise you
know when you're young and you're scared
you just don't know what's gonna happen
and you panic and I just want to tell
her like everything
you ever want plus more it's all gonna
happen
to myself every day I married Spy Kids
that's how we're gonna end the interview
that's that was perfect okay always a
pleasure Megan talking to you you're
such an inspiration and honestly
congratulations so proud of you you're
always killing it and inspiring so go
get it Queen I will be following and
cheerleading for you
random but you live in Canada I live in
L.A
this is also random are you single
uh yeah kinda yeah why what's going on
my older brother was singing
and he's 29 go check out his social
media okay booty booty where is he okay
like I'll give it a look would you want
to be my sister I mean I'm open to it I
hate but I'll go I mean we follow each
other on Instagram I will literally just
scour your thing and I will find I will
find your brother it's about to be 30 so
he's very mature he's a year and a half
sober he's great okay
okay it's a possibility I mean you just
never know in this world right the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen you're
the most beautiful thing girl you better
stop playing with me
okay I will find your brother go find
him he's so sweet is he here
we couldn't find him okay
I'm just gonna pull out my fan you got
me strapped down
[Applause]
I love you so much thank you for this
interview okay bye boo thank you so much